you must have had to deal with it once
you cannot be free in December
or at Christmas we do not give leave
what are actually
the rules about vacation days
and how when you can record it
if you want to request a holiday from the employer
must do so in writing and
at least two weeks in advance
but when can an employer refuse your leave
an employer may only refuse your leave request
when the company like you goes on leave
would get into big trouble
for a refusal of a holiday application
so there must always be good reasons
and with only an explanation of in December indicate
once no leave
an employer cannot get away
an employer does this to you now
always ask for an explanation in writing
and more clarity
responds
your employer not at all on your leave request
then you can
start from the law
that your holiday application has been approved
and you can go on vacation
arrange your holiday request on time and
stay tuned for
the next video
in which I explain how much employer
your holiday carrier may also withdraw